[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la ola de la variante omicron que
comienza a estabilizarse lentamente aquí
en europa y nos preguntamos si estamos
ahora sí ante el tramo final de la
pandemia nos acompañan en este estudio
florencia ángeles corresponsal de la w
radio aquí en francia bienvenida a
florencia ahora su invitación juana
torres doctor en ciencias políticas y
socióloga especializada en temas
laborales bienvenida a juana y en dúplex
nos acompañan nicolás gutiérrez melo
microbiólogo buenos dias nicolás muchas
gracias por la invitación
variante o micro en estamos ante el
final de esta pandemia hoy en primera
plana
[Música]
luz al final del túnel entre la
comunidad científica cada vez más voces
apuntan a esa esperanza la llegada de la
variante omicron que ha traído picos de
contagios exponenciales junto al aumento
de la vacunación en muchos países ha
hecho pensar que esta podría ser la ola
que marque el fin de la pandemia no es
que lakovic vaya a desaparecer pero sí
que pasa a ser una enfermedad que forme
parte de la vida cotidiana de los
ciudadanos con picos de contagios
controlados o sectorizados y deje de ser
ante todo una amenaza para millones de
personas hoy vamos a hablar de si
estamos cerca de ese escenario y lo
vamos a analizar también desde un punto
de vista político y social antes como
siempre repasemos algunas portadas que
nos deja la prensa en este asunto diario
abc en españa la mitad de europa se
contagiará en las próximas semanas la
oms se confirma que en los primeros
siete días de 2022 se contagiaron en
europa atención 7 millones de personas
diario libération aquí en francia kovic
esperanza en el horizonte dice el
rotativo francés que pese a que los
hospitales siguen en tensión muchos
indicadores invitan a la esperanza
gracias a la vacunación y a la menor
letalidad de la cepa omicron también
aquí en francia el diario/la de pez se
hace una pregunta en portada hacia el
fin de la pandemia
bueno pues les trasladó directamente esa
pregunta a florencia hay datos para
creer que en esa que estamos antes a la
luz al final del túnel hay síntomas de
que speed ya sí que es el final de la
pandemia yo creo que como tal si hay
datos de hecho lo decían ayer las
autoridades sanitarias francesas que
tenemos está disminución de 15 por
ciento menos 15% en las entradas a
reanimación a los cuidados intensivos
que también es un aliciente porque
sabemos que al menos ya no va a ver
también pues esta saturación en esos
hospitales no aunque la atención todavía
hospitalaria al menos en francia va a
continuar dos semanas más también vemos
que por ejemplo aunque tuvimos esta alza
de contagios que fue de manera muy
vertiginosa no tuvimos los cierres no no
tenemos los confinamientos como tuvimos
al inicio de la pandemia no no hubo
toques de queda en las escuelas
siguieron abiertas cosas que no vimos y
bueno y vemos también que pareciera que
no es tan grave o micro pero no bueno
gracias también a la vacunación entonces
yo creo que sí vamos a un poquito al
menos en este año al final del túnel no
puedo decir más porque a lo mejor
usuario de esta variante pero también el
hecho de por ejemplo vemos en reino
unido que han quitado ya las
restricciones y frank se lo acaba de
anunciar a partir del 2 de febrero y ya
tenemos que podemos dejar el cubrebocas
a un lado en el exterior también el
teletrabajo también se queda ya no va a
ser obligatorio nos tenemos una
perspectiva al menos mejor de que tantas
restricciones como vimos hace un año
pareciera que no van a pasar es verdad
que ya no hay toques de quedan y
confinamientos pero se han tomado
decisiones muy difíciles y muy duras el
pase sanitario la vacunación casi
obligatoria podríamos decirlo en muchos
países europeos medidas aceptadas por
una mayoría pero que han radicalizado
también a una parte de la población
juana desde la sociología cómo se
reparan estas fracturas cómo se vuelve a
reparar el tejido social que deja la
pandemia bueno yo creo que es importante
considerar el diálogo escuchar a las
posiciones que existen que hoy en día
así si tocamos el tema de las vacunas es
como antiguamente las familias no se
habla de política ni de religión todo
entonces implica escuchar la parte de
las personas que se han sentido
afectadas por esto y por ejemplo lo que
hizo el presidente macro diciendo los
voy a los voy a webber como dicen
en mi país no invita a escucha a
escuchar a las personas cómo se sienten
porque se manifiesta en contra contra
este tipo de medidas y quizás también
hay una falta de información de difusión
de una información de por qué es
necesario vacunarse porque
falta quizá falta una comprensión real
de eso y ahí hay un rol de los gobiernos
de informar y difundir una información
mucho más acabada comunicación además
formas no que el lenguaje sea que tengan
que sea menos de trazo grueso no que
tengo un lenguaje más crítica vamos
ahora esas palabras del presidente macro
que tristemente llevamos una
polarización que no ayuda a nadie y
justamente el tejido social se ha visto
bastante afectado por las restricciones
que tuvimos además pero también por el
impacto de tal cual de los cierres no es
lo mismo lo que vivimos en europa donde
hubo muchas ayudas por ejemplo a los
trabajadores que en américa latina donde
la economía informal es muy alta y qué a
diario se vio duramente afectado vamos a
preguntar el microbiólogo nicolás
gutiérrez me lo lo veíamos en las
portadas se advierte que la mitad de
europa va a estar contaminada en las
semanas que vienen que quiere decir esto
paradójicamente sería una buena noticia
podríamos decir que es paradójicamente
buena en tanto que la alta tasa de
contagios equivale a un incremento en la
inmunidad de la población en general y
esto probablemente va a ayudar a que se
cierre un poco esa brecha que no hemos
podido usar con la vacunación la
vacunación en europa ya está bastante
avanzada en algunos países con un poco
más del 70% en general
hay cierto porcentaje que ha sido
difícil de convencer difícil de llegar a
un número una tasa mucho más alta de
vacunación así que el hecho de que el
virus esté circulando
significa que muy probablemente estas
personas también entrarán en contacto
con el virus
al infectarse adquieran también
inmunidad digamos que no lo hace
deseable ni lo hace menos preocupante
actualmente la ocupación de unidades de
cuidados intensivos sigue aumentando
también menos quizás que en otras olas
pero igual la saturación del sistema de
salud
sigue siendo una preocupación y no
podemos dar marcha atrás hay que seguir
teniendo en cuenta las medidas y evitar
que se llega a un punto como pasó en las
primeras dos olas en las que tengamos
hospitales colapsados vamos viendo esos
matices no respecto a esta ola de
omicron de lograr que gran parte de la
población cree defensas contra el virus
el mundo saldría de la pandemia para
entrar a lo que se conoce como endemia
es decir cuando una enfermedad pasa a
formar parte de la vida cotidiana de los
ciudadanos con picos de contagios más o
menos controlados o sectorizados y deja
de ser una amenaza para millones de
personas esto supondría cambiar también
los protocolos para ir adaptando los a
una nueva realidad el otro día creo que
fue la ministra de sanidad española
quien hablaba de gripa al izar el micro
en el coronavirus una nueva fase y yo
creo que también lo decían aquí el
presidente abandona como lo dijo en
algún momento de que había que aprender
a vivir con el virus y yo creo que es
cierto no no podemos esperar a que
tengamos cero contagios para poder
regresar a su navidad eso no va a pasar
exactamente
y el hecho los protocolos sanitarios han
ido ajustando yo creo que van a seguir
ajustándose tenemos ahora también por
ejemplo en francia este reajuste o este
tratamiento de tuercas con el pase de
vacunación en el que ya se convirtió el
pase sanitario y finalmente es parte de
esta adaptación no el hecho de tener
este pase para poder acceder a lugares
de espacios públicos no dos conciertos
varios restaurantes cine bueno avión y
el tren que es también muy importante
como medio de transporte y vi que
también lo han dicho bueno eso se va a
ajustar conforme los datos
epidemiológicos vayan avanzando yo creo
que quizá después ya no habrá tantas
restricciones también para acceder estos
lugares pero de que se van a tener estas
medidas como el uso de cubrebocas o el
lavado de manos esas también llegaron
para quedarse en juana e imaginamos que
el mundo laboral también se tendrá que
ir adaptando a la nueva evolución del
virus pero claro venimos de dos años ya
de cambios absolutamente radicales cuál
es el peso que ha tenido que cargar el
teletrabajador en esta crisis y sobre
todo le preguntaría si se ha acentuado
la precariedad desde el teletrabajador
bueno el teletrabajo aparece como la
gran panacea en esta crisis para por un
lado salvar una cantidad importante de
empleos y por otro lado mantener a las
empresas funcionando sin embargo es
importante considerar que los puestos
tele trabajable es por así decirlo no es
la mayoría del mercado laboral de hecho
en francia se estima que es un 25 por
ciento de
profesiones
teletrabajadores y por ejemplo en
américa latina' que como decía florencia
de la informalidad es muy alta
considerablemente baja en relación al
total de la población ocupada pero en
relación a la población asalariada
también va entre 20 y 30 por ciento de
cada acceder al teletrabajo por lo tanto
es una realidad bastante desigual
considerando también las brechas
digitales que existen en las distintas
regiones del mundo
nicolás gutiérrez
hablando de tapas porque estamos
hablando de esta etapa final de esta luz
al final del túnel en qué etapa estamos
actualmente comparando no sé si se puede
con la trayectoria de otras pandemias
sabiendo que este en este caso ya
tenemos las vacunas estamos acercándonos
a la desaceleración en algunos países en
europa y algunas regiones de estados
unidos ya vemos qué
la estado le alcanzó su pico y los casos
comienzan a descender lentamente
y se esperaría que el después de esta
desaceleración llegar a la fase de
control ya que a diferencia de lo que ha
pasado con otras olas
en este caso gracias también en parte la
vacuna vemos que el número de contagios
se ha desligado de el número de casos
severos entonces esto pues evidencia que
nos acercamos a llegar hasta el punto en
el que podemos convivir con el virus aún
así el virus sigue circulando
esto depende claro que no vuelvan a
surgir nuevas variantes
probablemente sur
es incierto
en este momento decir cuándo y con qué
severidad aunque la probabilidad basado
en la biología del virus en biología de
las enfermedades infecciosas
tiende a punta entre futuras variantes
sean probablemente en menos patogénicas
claro el miedo a que puedan llegar
nuevas cepas aunque puedan ser aún menos
letales todavía que omicron porque las
vacunas y esa menor letalidad de omicron
son digamos las dos características que
están definiendo esta etapa que no
sabemos qué qué amplitud va a tener
cuándo se va a terminar pero sí que
tenemos ya unos rasgos claros con las
vacuna con las vacunas que con esa menor
la letalidad de omicron no se ha visto
en los datos buenos hechos ayer también
revisar esta gráfica que está en la
página del gobierno de francia y es muy
interesante como vimos realmente el pico
muy alto cuando empezó la pandemia en
todo en decesos en contagios en
hospitalizaciones y como ahora aunque se
vio está esta curva muy vertiginosa que
empezó a subir realmente no hubo ese
impacto en los decesos como como se ve
como se vio sin la vacuna no ahora
también yo creo que algo que nos hace
falta a todos y soltó a los a los
gobiernos
hincapié también en los medicamentos que
ya se están poco a poco aprobando y
puesto en el mercado para tratar también
está este virus esto también ayudará a
que las hospitalizaciones desciendan y
desciendan y también los decesos no las
muertes bueno es un momento de apertura
que en francia por cierto que el
gobierno acaba de anunciar un calendario
de reapertura que en francia el gobierno
de macrón para el mes de febrero de
vuelta a la normalidad vuelve los
conciertos las discotecas bueno vuelve
la vida esto yo creo es un chute al
menos de optimismo después de tanto
sufrimiento juana esto socialmente se
nota en la presión
efectivamente yo creo que una de las
faltas más importantes que sentimos
todos durante la pandemia fue la falta
de socialización pero sobre todo cara a
cara que es donde las tecnologías de
información y comunicación jugaron un
rol muy importante para hacernos sentir
esta socialización aunque no sea
presencia por lo tanto juega un rol
esencial yo diría poder encontrar estos
espacios de encuentro para las personas
nuevamente y yo creo que también va a
contribuir mucho al descenso de las
enfermedades psicológicas que también
trajo el commit como consecuencia del
aislamiento un punto muy interesante
vamos a seguir desarrollándolo a vuelta
de esta breve pausa a quien en primera
plana
[Música]
y
nueva crisis política en honduras
argumentando traición la presidenta
electa xiomara castró expulsó a 18
diputados de su partido por oponerse a
escoger a uno de sus aliados como nuevo
líder del congreso castro llamó a
movilizaciones este sábado tenemos
análisis
en alemania el partido unión demócrata
cristiana eligió al conservador fredrik
más como un nuevo líder después de la
derrota de la connect colectividad en
las elecciones de septiembre
merz prometió cambiar el rumbo dictado
durante 16 años por la ex canciller
angela merkel
fin de semana de protestas en europa
miles de personas anti vacunas salieron
a las calles de parís londres y
estocolmo para rechazar las órdenes de
vacunación contra el joven 19 los
llamados pases sanitarios que certifican
la aplicación del fármaco para poder
entrar a lugares de ocio
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz iniciamos en honduras
donde se desató una nueva crisis
política este viernes la presidenta
electa xiomara castró expulsó a 18
diputados de su partido en el congreso
calificándolos de traidores el hecho se
produjo luego de que los legisladores
decidieron no respetar el pacto
alcanzado para escoger a luis redondo
del partido salvador de honduras como el
nuevo líder del congreso y en su lugar
votaron por jorge cálix uno de los
expulsados la jornada en la que se
escogían los directores provisionales
del parlamento derivó en peleas y
enfrentamientos castro llamó a
movilizaciones para este sábado para
hablar de ese tema saludamos en la
capital hondureña al esther ramírez
analista y director de transparencia y
gobernanza de la asociación para una
sociedad más justa en honduras señor
ramírez bienvenidos france24 qué
implicaciones tiene en el congreso que
el que fue nombrado como su nuevo líder
sea uno de los expulsados
señor ramírez
le pedimos por favor que active de su
micrófono para poder escuchar
lo que va a suceder ahora es justamente
de que el congreso se va a fraccionar
aún más y no solamente es el impacto del
fraccionamiento sino los temas en la
agenda de 10 es el meollo del asunto en
este momento el gobierno de xiomara
castró un gobierno de alianza con el
pastor de comer rápido salvador de
honduras y habían prometido parte de su
campaña en un fuerte embate a la
corrupción y la impunidad del país las
estructuras de poder que lograron
fraccionar el congreso nacional el día
de hoy justamente
su gran amenaza era la posibilidad de
terminar en la cárcel y la posibilidad
de perder todos sus activos más los
malogrados entonces el asunto aquí es
continuar con esta cultura de impunidad
que vienen haciendo desde
sra qué implicaciones o más bien cómo
afecta a esta nueva crisis la
gobernabilidad de xiomara castró a menos
de una semana de que tomó el poder
bueno posiblemente ya la luna de miel ya
terminó sin haber llegado al poder ya la
luna de miel al menos ya de la alianza
del pueblo que se llama estar unión
entre el partido libertad y refundación
y el partido salvador de honduras y el
impacto que va a tener a nivel de
gobierno es que sin duda alguna lo va a
debilitar y va a tener serios
limitaciones en términos de aprobar
leyes y de revisar leyes anteriores que
habían sido lesivas para los intereses
de la población estaba el asunto también
de las cosas sedes estas zonas de
desarrollo económico exclusivas quedaban
o una legislación especial para los
inversionistas y que a muchos afectaban
los intereses comunitarios afectaban en
el medio ambiente
ese tipo de temas en la agenda
legislativa van a comprar una regla muy
grande y también el gran pedido por una
comisión internacional en producción que
había sido la carta de presentación de
la campaña política deseo para castró
que va a tener realmente un revés y
posiblemente no se llega a instaurar
porque acordémonos de qué es el congreso
que aprueba los tratados internacionales
en nuestro país entonces estos son los
impactos y obviamente también un fuerte
en torno a las condiciones económicas
del país que ya el proceso electoral
había mejorado en la estabilidad y se
había mejorado la gobernabilidad y ahora
no los inversionistas no se van a sentir
muy cómodos claris donde hay muy
inestable señor él está ramiro muchas
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en france
24 cambiamos de tema y vamos a alemania
la unión democratacristiana de la ex
canciller angela merkel eligió a la a
frédéric maire como presidente de la
colectividad durante un congreso virtual
celebrado este sábado en la sede del
partido merz un conservador de 66 años y
fuerte crítico de merkel tendrá a su
cargo reconstruir el partido de la ex
canciller después de la derrota
electoral que sufrió el saliente
presidente de la cdu armin la 7 juan
pablo lo q me detalla en el siguiente
informe quienes frydrych merz
el tercer intento fue el vencido para
freak merge con una votación abrumadora
el conservador se convirtió en el nuevo
líder de la unión demócrata cristiana
alemana después de haberse postulado en
2018 y 2021 nació en 1955 en una zona
rural de renania del norte westfalia el
estado más poblado del país fue
legislador del parlamento europeo
durante cinco años y después de que se
unió al legislativo alemán en 1994 se ha
presentado como un gran crítico del
gobierno de la ex canciller angela
merkel dejó el parlamento en 2009 pero
regresó recientemente y desde entonces
parece que sus ideas se han
flexibilizado ha mostrado mayor
acercamiento hacia las mujeres y los
votantes jóvenes anunció que promoverá
un cambio en la legislación para
permitir que las parejas lgtb y adopten
niños este sábado en su ratificación el
líder de 66 años prometió unir al
partido después de años críticos bien
tuits uribe en la cdv hemos vivido tres
años difíciles y hemos sufrido una dura
derrota en las elecciones federales del
año pasado pero este periodo ya ha
quedado atrás para bueno estar suave y
mets ya
creada desde la segunda guerra mundial
en 1945 la cdu va dirigido el gobierno
alemán la mayor parte del tiempo merz
todavía debe esperar una confirmación
por escrito para asumir el cargo pues la
votación de los delegados se realizó de
manera virtual por normas de la pandemia
y variadas ciudades de europa vivieron
protestas o este sábado en rechazo a la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 a
continuación nombre de recuento sobre la
situación el personal del servicio
nacional de salud del reino unido salió
a las calles de londres para rechazar la
venida encuesta por el gobierno que
obliga a los trabajadores sanitarios a
aplicarse el fármaco a partir del
primero de abril de este año de no
cumplir con la medida no podrán seguir
ejerciendo sus campos
en parís la capital francesa miles de
personas marcharon contra el polémico
pase vacunal aprobado en la asamblea
nacional y que entra en vigor este lunes
con carteles los manifestantes
calificaron la nueva medida como
divisiva y se refirieron a ella como el
aparte y pues desde ahora ya no bastará
con mostrar una prueba negativa de kobe
19 para acceder a lugares de ocio
al grito de libertad una multitud de
personas se concentró en estocolmo para
protestar contra la decisión del
gobierno sueco de recomendar a
restaurantes sitios culturales y otros
lugares de ocio que también exijan a sus
clientes un certificado de vacunación la
medida se produjo luego de que el país
registrará un aumento en el número de
contagios por kobe 19 causado por la
variante
terminamos en la ciudad medieval
española de toledo que ha sido
reconocida por tener la vista nocturna
más hermosa del mundo famosos monumentos
como el alcázar la catedral primada de
santamaría y el monasterio de san juan
de los reyes se iluminan cada noche para
turistas y locales el galardón fue
otorgado por la oficina de turismo de
japón
es una escena que ha sido admirada
durante siglos a la luz del día a la
vista de toledo ya es impresionante pero
a medida que el sol se pone sobre la
ciudad medieval española revela una
premiada vista panorámica que ahora ha
sido reconocida como la mejor del mundo
que se ve todo el casco además él
el cielo y todo super super bonito y
claro luego toda la historia que hay
detrás de toledo que es una ciudad super
super importante a nivel a nivel
histórico te sienta orgulloso de poder
decir que la bronca va más bonita del
mundo que esas son palabras mayores el
premio fue otorgado a toledo por la
oficina japonesa de turismo en parte
porque cambió la iluminación tradicional
de su ciudad por luces leds más
eficientes cada noche en diferentes
colores iluminan algunos de sus
monumentos más famosos
toledo está a menos de una hora de
madrid y es un éxito entre los turistas
que buscan hacer una excursión de un día
fuera de la capital española
también es uno de los sitios
culturalmente más ricos del país
declarado patrimonio de la humanidad por
la unesco con una historia que se
remonta a más de 2000 años
hasta que es informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras emisiones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días
intuitivo rápido y en cuatro lenguas
france24 puntocom liberté égalité
actualice
continuamos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de si esta o la de la variante
o micrón supone o viene a ser el
escenario del fin de la pandemia lo
hacemos con florencia ángeles
corresponsal de la w radio aquí en
francia para torres doctor en ciencias
políticas y sociología y en dúplex nos
acompaña también a distancia nicolás
gutiérrez melo microbiólogo hablamos de
la luz al final del túnel pero ojo
muchos científicos señalan que hasta que
un 80 por ciento de la población mundial
no esté vacunada la normalización podría
tardar más tiempo y nuevas variantes
podrían aparecer claro florencia el gran
dilema es si aparece otra variante más
letal que un micrón que suponga un
retroceso en todos estos avances todo
parece indicar que no pero hasta que no
hay un 80% de la población vacuna el cij
vamos con varios criterios todavía en
este fin de la pandemia porque es el
juego del equilibrista hasta donde
podemos abrir y sin que esto suponga que
va a haber más contagios ya sabemos que
también ha más contagioso más
circulación del virus también la
probabilidad de que surjan más variantes
entonces tampoco hay que cantar victoria
y decir bueno ya no hay nada no olvidaré
los gestos barrera olvidar las
precauciones creo que eso sí tiene que
ser pero en lo que decía juana son los
instantes hay que retomar también el
vínculo social físico
que esto
carrera ha acarreado muchos problemas
psicológicos había también un reportaje
de liberación que salió hace unos días
sobre la tasa de suicidios en jóvenes
que aumentó de manera muy importante en
este año no
había 64 por ciento de aumento en gestos
solidarios lo cual es muchísimo hubo un
paso a las urgencias bastante fuerte en
este año y por qué porque realmente los
vínculos sociales
físicos se han destruido y todo pasa por
la digitalización que ha ayudado
evidentemente no a que podamos estar en
contacto pero no hay que olvidar que
también tenemos que regresar a tener
este contacto físico que tan tan es
importante para la salud psicológica
vamos a preguntar al micro biólogo
nicolás gutiérrez - sobre este punto y
planteó directamente el dilema las
vacunas funcionan y protegen pero claro
no se puede vacunar cada cuatro meses no
puede ser esto una estrategia en europa
mucho menos cuando hay países tan
rezagados en la vacunación a nivel
mundial al mismo tiempo nos falta
todavía para llegar a la inmunidad como
hemos comentado para llegar a esa
inmunidad de rebaño es el gran dilema
como decía florencia el gran jo de
equilibrista de vivir de convivir con el
virus no
dos cosas a tener en cuenta y la primera
es que
esto es un esfuerzo conjunto y quizás en
europa
podemos verlo claramente hay países en
los que las tasas de vacunación son
extremadamente altos como son el caso
quizás de dinamarca español portugal y
otros de mercedes son bastante bajos
como en bulgaria rumanía hasta que no se
logre un
porcentaje de vacunación alto en general
en la población total el virus va a
seguir circulando y va a ser más difícil
y lograr esta fase de control de la que
hemos venido hablando
la segunda cosa que toca tener en cuenta
es que si quizás cada cuatro meses es el
efecto excesivo de una vacuna pero ya se
han empezado a seis años clínicos en los
que se han diseñado vacunas que combinan
los antígenos contra el coronavirus y
los antígenos contra la influenza
como una posible estrategia de
vacunación anual lo que nos ayude de
nuevo a llegar hasta está para la que
podemos convivir con el virus sin que
signifique
un mayor riesgo
de este escenario juana que nos deja el
final de la pandemia claro hay
realidades que han venido para quedarse
una de ellas parece ser el teletrabajo
en menor o mayor medida pero hemos dado
un impulso tan fuerte que parece que el
teletrabajo va a ser una de las
realidades que más una de las
consecuencias que más va a dejar la
pandemia no antes hablamos de la
importancia de ese vínculo físico pero
quizás la pregunta es este aumento del
teletrabajo no puede individualizar nos
más y fragilizar el lazo social los
sindicatos
absolutamente de hecho el trabajo
históricamente se ha comprendido como
manera de integrarse a la sociedad y de
socialización del espacio por esencia de
socialización por lo tanto efectivamente
genera un
debilitamiento del vínculo social no
obstante yo por ejemplo en temas de
sindicatos si pensamos en los
trabajadores de plataforma en américa
latina' los de repartos sobre todo que
es un sector que se incrementó muchísimo
y también uno de los más precarios se
han constituido más de diez sindicatos a
partir del 2019 donde el primero de
ellos fue en colombia por lo tanto
si bien dentro del espacio el
teletrabajo existe un espacio de
individualización también existen otros
espacios donde se está forjando este
vínculo social de otras maneras
florencia el teletrabajo ha llegado para
quedarse con todo lo que eso implica
respecto a la importancia del vínculo
físico de la importancia de ese vínculo
físico que necesitamos y que es una de
las consecuencias del fin de la pandemia
es decir el teletrabajo ha llegado para
quedarse y al mismo tiempo ese vínculo
físico que necesitamos
y realmente el problema digamos pero yo
creo que por ejemplo el hecho de que las
empresas entiendan que se puede trabajar
que se puede trabajar a distancia
pero que también no sea de manera
obligatoria pienso que va a abrir un
poco a que las personas lo decidan por
sí mismas no no es lo mismo estar en
casa a fuerza no que por ejemplo
programar a lo mejor te quedas en casa
uno o dos días pero si vas al trabajo a
estas reuniones que a veces se necesita
también para contrarrestar puntos de
opinión no entonces yo creo que si es
algo positivo también para el mercado
del trabajo con el mercado laboral
siempre y cuando no sea una obligación
que puedas tú ir al trabajo ver a tus
colegas es necesario y también se
necesita para la salud psicológica
porque a lo mejor estando en casa tienes
otras tareas que a lo mejor estás ahí
ahí y sabiendo que están pendientes no
sobre todo también las trato la carga
para las mujeres no siendo que también
eres ama de casa y además están los
niños y el trabajo entonces no tienes un
break en todo el día de esta realidad le
quería preguntar a juana porque de la
realidad del mundo sociolaboral que nos
deja la pandemia mención especial hay
que hacer para las mujeres sin duda son
las trabajadoras de trabajo e hijos en
casa cuidados higiene las que han
soportado el aplastante peso de la
pandemia bueno lo llevan haciendo siglos
pero todavía se ha focalizado más
durante la pandemia se ha obviado esta
carga se ha puesto en valor esta carga
yo creo que no se ha puesto en valor
como históricamente no se ha puesto en
valor y efectivamente para las mujeres
ha significado un retroceso en distintos
planos
dentro del teletrabajo obviamente con
mayores cuidados en casa y también por
ejemplo la cepal muestra que en américa
latina' el retroceso de la participación
laboral en las mujeres significa un
retroceso de 10 años como estábamos hace
10 años por lo tanto las mujeres han
sido las grandes
víctimas del mercado laboral en esta
pandemia nada nuevo bajo el sol por otro
lado
hablábamos antes de la importancia de la
comunicación
respecto a las vacunas para invitar para
apelar a que la gente se vacune le
quiero preguntar a nuestro microbiólogo
sobre la vulgarización científica en que
hemos fallado hablamos antes del
importante de la comunicación en que
hemos fallado para que miles de personas
siguen sin querer vacunarse la violencia
científica
se da como un hecho pero la gente no
solo reaccionar racionalmente a estos
hechos sino que se nos ha olvidado la
respuesta emocional y esto requiere
diferentes estrategias de comunicación y
creo que hace más difícil que la gente
quiera escuchar la evidencia científica
y es que nos han enseñado que la ciencia
es de respuestas absolutas
y de hecho es todo lo contrario es
importante
y hacer entender a la gente que las
decisiones se han tomado con la mejor
información que se disponía en su
momento pero que día a día aprendemos
más entendemos más y a medida que avanza
el conocimiento se adaptan las medidas
y por eso quizás es necesario
y cambiar las medidas que se han tomado
previamente entonces creo que es un poco
en parte de la comunidad científica
aprender
entender esa parte emocional del público
así como de la sociedad
tener una disposición más abierta a el
camino y las incertidumbres que pueda
haber en el conocimiento científico a
medida que hacemos investigación
una evolución tal como lo explica el
microbiólogo nicolás gutiérrez me lo que
ha habido durante toda la pandemia pero
trasladó la misma pregunta a la mesa en
florencia hemos fallado en esta
comunicación sensible que enlaza ciencia
con decisiones políticas yo creo que sí
ha habido sin duda una falta de
comunicación que llegue a convencer
quizá la gente que todavía lo duda por
para la vacuna pero también es muy
difícil
como sociedad de entender quizá estos
cambios tan rápidos porque nunca tuvimos
jamás es tecnología o frenarla como
ahora son una vacuna que que salió
realmente muy rápido a mucha gente le
causó este recelo no de ay qué extraño o
no el hecho de que se esté obligando no
sé creo que hubo hubo una falta así de
comunicación y también de como
ciudadanos hemos preparado a una
pandemia y en la respuesta y qué bueno
también por otra parte que la tecnología
y el avance científico ha hecho que
tengamos una respuesta tan rápida pero
eso nos ha entendido pese al duro golpe
económico que la pandemia significó para
millones de personas puntualmente para
el 99% de la humanidad los 10 hombres
más ricos del planeta duplicaron con
creces sus fortunas en estos dos años
así lo indica el más reciente informe de
la organización internacional oxfam
publicado esta misma semana
juana esto confirma que la pandemia ha
sido un factor determinante en el
crecimiento de las desigualdades un
ejemplo puntual es la producción y el
reparto de vacunas pero también el
reparto de la riqueza
pero el reparto de vacuna es una
consecuencia también del gran reparto de
la riqueza de hecho en efecto creo que
esta falta de vacunas en países menos
desarrollados muestra una desigualdad de
base de esto y también quizás juega un
factor en el sentido que las personas
que no quieren vacunarse no crean en
esta modalidad porque si se ve un
negocio donde personas enriquecen de una
manera excesiva y los mismos países que
siempre han estado en una posición menos
desarrollada no acceden a las vacunas
muestra también un argumento para estas
personas que no quieren vacunarse y por
otro lado también es esta desigualdad
mostrado que las personas en países
desarrollados mueren la mitad que los
países no desarrollados que mueren el
doble por no tener acceso a salud el
informe de oxfam
bueno señala aspectos realmente
demoledores leo textualmente el dinero
acumulado por los más ricos podría
servir para producir suficientes vacunas
para el mundo financiar servicios de
salud y protección social universales y
aún así esos 10 millonarios seguirán
teniendo 8 mil millones de dólares más
que antes de la pandemia es es brutal no
pensar después de lo que ha pasado el
mundo pensar que esas diferencias han
aumentado exactamente y sobre todo
porque mucha gente dice bueno aquí le
benefician al hecho de que yo me vacuné
es un negocio es porque las
farmacéuticas están lucrando con eso y
quizá no sea los que están de más ricos
no son realmente por el momento los que
están en esta área de biotecnología sin
embargo es cierto que tristemente los
que ya tenían dinero ahora por ejemplo
pues de besòs no de amazon finalmente la
gente como se hacía entregar con lo cual
nos quitaría porque además una empresa
de biotecnología puede enriquecerse lo
cual lo cual no quita que la que la
vacuna sea segura sea eficiente y sea es
decir sea necesario evidentemente cuando
investiga si cuando innova también hay
empresas detrás
vemos lo cual no quita el valor
científico por que por supuesto lo tiene
muchísimas gracias por haber una
acompañado en este programa juana
florencia ha sido un placer
muchas gracias también a nicolás
gutiérrez melo microbiólogo que nos ha
acompañado con todos los datos
científicos que hemos podido aportar en
este en primera plana destinado no sé si
a ver la luz al final del túnel lo vamos
a ir viendo en las próximas semanas ya
todos ustedes muchísimas gracias nos
vemos la próxima semana en primera plana
[Música]